字幕: Yuri Ueda
校正: Natsuhiko Mizutani
私が長年やっております仕事の
スタンダップコメディ
「えっ そんなの聞いたことないよ」と
日本人の人に言われるのは
もちろんのことなんですが
こと 日本人スタンダップコメディアン
ということになりますと
本場アメリカ アメリカ人からも
「嘘だろう 聞いた事ねえぞ」に
なってしまいます
世界中で私以外 本当に誰も
やってないんだなと実感することがあります
アメリカ入国です
皆さんも アメリカ入国の時は
入国審査官から
名前と仕事を聞かれると思います
で それらに答えると入国です
が 私の場合は少し違います
入国審査官が名前と仕事を聞いてきますので
「小池良介です　仕事は
スタンダップコメディです」と言いますと
退屈そうにしていた入国審査官
むくっと顔を上げまして
私のパスポートを見て
「（英語） 日本人なのに」と言ってきます
この意味はどちらかというと
お前みたいな日本人にコメディ出来るのか
といったニュアンスを感じますので
私は「（英語）えぇ
私はスタンダップコメディアンですよ」と
「日本人もコメディアンいるんだよ」
と言いますと
「あ そうですか　わかりました
なるほど ありがとうございます　どうぞ」
とはならないです
代わりに
「あ そうですか　なるほど」
「じゃあここで今から 私にジョークを言って
笑わしてくださいよ」と言われます
「（英語）何かジョークを言ってくれ」
というこのやりとりを
ニューヨーク　ロサンジェルス　デトロイト
ミネアポリス　シカゴ　ワシントン
あらゆる空港で私毎回言われております
パスポートとグリーンカード
またはESTAで入国できるところですが
私の場合は これらに加えて
この入国ジョークなるものをいつも携えて
皆さんと同じように並んで ウケるのかどうか
いつもドキドキしながら待っております
緊張に包まれたあの入国審査のあの場所で
入国審査官の高らかなる
笑い声が聞こえますと
それは私 世界唯一日本人
スタンダップコメディアンの
アメリカ入国OKのサインで
これを25年やっております
日本人スタンダップコメディアン
このように体ひとつでマイク１本
ニューヨーカーに英語で笑わせる
お笑いのようなもん
というふうに説明する人もいますが
この説明はあまり好きではありません
というのも これを言いますと
日本人の方から
「英語でコメディーなんて 英語がもともと
上手い方だったんですよね」とか
「ニューヨークでお笑いなんて
笑いのセンスが元々あったから
だからできるんでしょ」と言われます
まぁ日本人がニューヨークで
コメディやろうとした場合に
この上手い英語と笑いのセンス
必要不可欠とパッと浮かぶと思いますが
この２つの要素 私持っておりません
昔無くて今有る　とかではなく
今もこれ無いままでやっております
実は私 耳に障害を持っております
幼少期の頃から ある一定の音域が
全く聞こえません
そこに 英語の音域が
ズボーッと入ってるようで
今でも英語の聞き取りは 半分以上は
勘に頼ってるという
そんな状態でやっております
それと アメリカに渡ってからの
テストで偶然発覚します―
この極度のADHDと
極度のアスペルガー症候群
この影響だったと思いますし
今もそうなんですけど
なんか落ち着くことができないですね
すぐこう集中できず ウロウロしてしまうので
英語の成績は２でした
10段階の学校の２という有様でした
さらに 私の出身地はここ愛知県
お笑いに全く縁のない地域ですよね
車を作るのは皆さん大好きなようなんですが
笑いに関しては全く
興味ないまま一生過ぎていく
緑も豊かで素晴らしい街だと
思うんですが　お笑いは不毛です
人口は未だに増え続けてると
そういう そんな町らしいんですけど
日本で有数のお笑い過疎が
今でも進んでる そんな地域です
私が英語の能力 そして笑いのセンス
ここら辺に備わってなかったというのは
十分な裏付けになると思います
「あ なるほど　じゃあ かなり
努力した方なんですね」
と言われますが 努力は普通です
そんな 誰からの目からも見ても 異常なほど
壮絶な努力をしたということは してません
どんなに努力しても出来なかったという
そっちの経験の方が多いので
私は努力は信用しておりません　し
努力を信用してるという人も
私は信用することはできません
笑いのセンスもなく
英語も上手くなく 努力もなく 才能もなく
「一体どうやって ニューヨークでコメディを
プロのレベルで出来ているんですか」
と言われます
何かを成し遂げるのに必要なのは
この努力と才能だけなんでしょうか
もう一つの要素があるじゃないですか
このもう一つの要素
実は誰にも大切にされてません
もったいないな といつも思います
ですが このもう一つの要素が
私にとってのニューヨーク 全てでした
その要素が才能でもなく 努力でもなく
「助けられる 助けが入る」という要素です
「はぁ？助け」って感じですよね
もったいないと思います
ぜひ皆さんにも この「助け」という
要素を使えるようにと思って
私の時間があると思っております
私がニューヨークに渡った時
才能と努力 本当になかったです
ただ ニューヨークのコメディ業界の
激しい荒波に抗う
ただ それだけ
何の成果も出てない そんな私に
ニューヨーカーたちが声をかけてくれました
「リオ あそこのコメディークラブ
お前出たがってたじゃないか」
「オーナーと話をつけといたから
今から行って来いよ」とか
「今度 テレビでコメディ番組があって
コメディアン探してるんだ
お前ぴったりだと思うから
ここにメールしろよ
マイクって言うんだ　電話とかどうだ」
これら全て 本来ライバルであるはずの
コメディアンたちの言葉でした
不思議でしょうがなかったです
成功へのテーブル　成功への椅子は
数限られてます
ライバルは少ない方がいいに決まってます
なのに 彼らは助けてくれるんですね
彼らの紹介のお陰で 私は
コメディーの出演機会を得ていきます
コメディー番組のテレビにも決まります
ニューヨークのコメディークラブの
レギュラーの座を射止めることもありました
私がレギュラーになった分
外れるコメディアンが出てきます
その外れるコメディアンは
私を紹介してくれた当の本人
彼らだったりもします
なのに引き続き 彼らは私を
助けてくれます
なぜか
まず 彼らは誰かに助けられて
ここにいたから だったんですね
自分がされたことを ただ 外国人である
僕にもした というそれだけですが
まぁアメリカ ニューヨークというと
何かこう奪われたら奪い返すとか
やられたらやり返すというイメージですが
同様に この助けられたら助け返してしまう
この助け助けられのメカニズムが
強烈に働く街で
このメカニズム　仕事以外の
実生活にも及んでいます
印象的な出来事がありました
貧困日本人留学生として
ニューヨークで暮らしている私には
同様に貧困な日本人の留学生３人がいまして
この４人でごくたまにレストランに行きます
貧乏人なのにレストランなんですか　ですが
これは貧乏人の知恵で 行くのは
韓国レストランに限り上手くいく方法です
４人で行ってオーダーするのは
一番安いカルビ 一皿だけです
そこには「突き出し」が付いてきます
この突き出しこそ 私たちの目的です
日本の居酒屋と違って 韓国レストランの
突き出し ７個も８個も出てきますよね
キムチ　ナムル　ゼンマイ　タマゴ　サラダ
お魚　スープ　寒天とか
でも全部このぐらいちっちゃい
ちっちゃいお皿なので
４人で食べるとあっという間に
なくなってしまうので おかわりです
このように突き出しをおかわりする人は
まずいません　私たちだけです
非常に目立ちます
が　目的なので おかわりをし続けます
何回おかわりをしたか覚えてないくらい
もう10回を超えたぐらいで
奥からオーナーとおぼしき韓国人が
私たちのテーブルにやってきます
４人座っていてオーダーは
一番安いカルビ 一皿
それを見て 全てが理解できたようで
一つだけ質問をしてきました
「お前たちは日本人なのか」でした
私が「日本人です」
それを聞くと
彼はそのまま奥へ戻ってしまいました
瞬間的に 「あ つまみ出される」と
それ以外は思わなかったです
しばらくして その韓国人オーナー
私たちのテーブルに帰ってきて何をしたか
４人に一人に一皿ずつのカルビを
こう置いてってくれるんですね
ちょっと大盛りなぐらいなやつを
皆さん４人に置いてって
私はびびってしまい「すみません
注文してません 払えませんよ」て言いますと
彼 「これは私のおごりです」というので
「なんでこんなことしてくれるんですか」
て言いますと
その韓国人のオーナー 以前 日本に
住んでいたことがあったと言っておりました
東京の新大久保駅あたりと言っておりました
祖国を離れて貧しく暮らしている彼を
この新大久保駅の人たちがいろいろ施して
助けてくれると言っておりました
ご飯を食べるお金がない時なんかは
近くのレストランのオーナーが
色々食べさせてくれて
しのげれたと言っておりました
しばらくするとその彼 日本を離れ
ニューヨークへ流れ着きます
そこでレストランをします
成功します
が　ニューヨークのレストラン業界も厳しく
ただ荒波にもまれている間に
新大久保駅の人達にお礼を言う機会がなかった
と言ってるところに来たのが私たちです
ご飯を食べるお金もない私たちを見て
当時の自分と重ねてしまって
彼曰く「同じことをしてしまったよ」
店をその後出て 他の３人の留学生は口々に
「ラッキーだったな」「いい人で良かったな」
私だけは少し違うイメージを持ってました
「あ　また 助けられた」
助けはこうやって脈々と流れているんだ と
こういうことを言いますと
こういう風に考えちゃう人も
いるかもしれませんよね
そんなに厳しいニューヨークでこれならば
世界中どこでも成功出来ちゃいますよね
だって みんな助けてくれちゃうんですもんね
みんな助けられて みんな成功しちゃいます
確かにこの助け助けられの
メカニズムは鉄板です
私が努力とか才能が限界があって
しょうもないなと時々思ってしまうのは
どちらも我が事だからです
社会を無視した いわば
マスターベーションのような考え方だからです
助けは相手が要ります
助けられるのにも相手が要ります
助けは社会そのものだと思ってます
助けの流れこそ社会の流れ
助けは助けられた相手が
嬉しいばかりではなく
助けた本人も「ああ 俺は社会でも
役に立つ存在なんだ」という
社会の醍醐味を実感できる貴重な機会です
人は本来助けたい
そういう生物なんだと思ってます―
が 実際は 全員が助けられてませんし
全員が助けてません
実はこの助け助けられのメカニズムには
強烈な一つの例外があります
この例外にくらうと あんなに
助けたいと思ってる人たちが
急に助けを拒否してしまいます
そんな例外―
それは助けを期待していると
助けてもらえないです
本当に不思議なんですけど この助けを
期待してる心はすぐバレてしまいます
同じ作業をしてるんですけど
助けを欲しいなというこのスケベ心
すぐ見透かされてしまうんですね
これは私の実体験からです
こちらの写真をどうぞ
これは 私が他人をあてにする期待する心
そして 結果にだけ期待するこのスケベ心に
溢れかえってる26歳の私です
お前はダンスの才能の塊だ という
そういう評価に期待してました
これは踊ってる写真というよりは
期待に踊らされてるという そういう写真です
それを実証するかのように
この後すべての期待に裏切られます
何も残りません
大きな大きな
挫折感
失望感
というかもう大きな
忘れてしまいました（笑）
大きな大きな挫折感　失望感　大きな敗北感
ま そういうものなんですけど（笑）
大きな挫折感が あまりにも大きすぎて
こう癒すことができなさすぎて
無心のまましたのが 笑いのネタでした
皮肉なもので 私が無心で無欲で
笑いをしてるところに助けはやって来ます
大きな敗北感の中 大きな挫折感の中
そこから脱出しようとしている人を
人はほっとかないんだなと思いました
これが大きな契機となって
私は期待するということを全くやめました
同時に 助けが来るようになりました
言い換えるならば 応援されたんだと思います
笑いというのは本当不思議で
期待をしてると必ず裏切ってくれるんですね
それがまぁ 今日もそうなんですけど
きっと皆さんもスタンダップコメディアンが
スピーカーにいるんだったら
きっと楽しい笑いにあふれる舞台に
なるんじゃないか
という期待をしていたのかもしれませんし
私は私で
お笑い過疎地なんだから
笑いなんか起きるかよという
ある種 期待をしてたんですけど
いい意味でちょっと裏切られましたよね
この笑いの厳しさを教えてくれた街が
ニューヨークです
そのニューヨークにこの舞台が終わったら
すぐ戻らなければいけませんが
この時期なので少し入国が心配です
もし私が入国できなかったら それは
感染症という理由もあるんでしょうけど
私の場合は入国ジョークが滑った
ということも考えられると思います
こんな偉そうに言ってても まだまだ ね
ちょっとぐらいウケないかなという期待を
しちゃうもんだな という風に思ってます
期待とは裏切られるためにある　です
もしうまく入国できなかったら
このお笑い過疎地　お笑い不毛の地
愛知県にまた戻ってこなければいけません
その時は 皆さんお付き合い
していただきたいと思います
その時はよろしくお願いします
本日はどうもありがとうございます
（拍手）